what would happen they're pretty good i
mean you know it's funny that you know
those flat earth videos you know that
gets uh demonized so much but uh it's
kind of a competition you know the earth
is kind of shaped like a sausage
mcgregor okay i have to say this
it gets injected with syrup we can't get
we can't get up
but i do think uh space is a little
elliptical well i'm a moon landing
expert because of joe rogan okay let me
just tell you something the idea that we
could get to the van island radiation
belts in 1969 through 1972 you know we
had uh we went through it twice both
ways it's absolutely impossible yet that
same technology that was able to do it
then we accidentally destroyed it it's a
painful process back up again you like
just because
they went through it doesn't mean they
went through it right you know what i
mean i don't know i mean what they saw
the fantasies
lived for a long time i'm sure and and
maybe they got the best medical
treatment but i remember astronaut
saying it was crazy i was seeing stars
it was like i was there and it's like we
we know that when you see the sparkles
it's because you're being bombarded with
high levels of radiation so like
you've seen the press conference tim
after they came back from the moon they
looked like their dogs had died i don't
care what anybody says joe rogan
actually argued two different times on
pin teller's show that the moon landing
was totally fake made very compelling
arguments and then walked it back and i
love you joe i'm just saying you know uh
you know it is what it is and and you're
gonna be like well alex you know you're
just some conspiracy theorist idiot i'm
just telling you you look at the footage
i think there's a compelling argument as
to why they would fake it i just uh but
i just also think like strapping some
dudes to a rocket isn't as complicated
as a lot of people think it is
well i don't know about that i mean you
know in trump just even said you know he
was trolling elon musk and said his
rockets go nowhere i don't know i mean
you know rocket technology you know
space travel i'll just be honest with
you you know what is it pushing off of
you know uh and somebody would say oh
well
i don't know i think space is kind of
fake but what am i going to say yeah i
mean you know what do i know i'm an
idiot uh but yeah what they tell us you
know i just i don't think i get them i
get the feeling i'll snopes you that
you're partially true or partially false
whatever you want to call it that that
they did print fake documentation of
people on the moon stanley kubrick for
instance did video in case they didn't
have enough footage from when they went
that's a fact you know that for sure
yeah well i think the theory is that
it's all faked because kubrick's footage
proves it but i think that what they did
both they went there just in case they
didn't have enough um propaganda to
convince people and make them excited
that they shot more in a studio they
were going to interlace and some of it
may or may not be interlaced i don't
know but i don't see evidence that we
didn't i i most of everything in society
has told me that we have and that we
still do go into space well just google
the fake michael collins picture that
they used a picture with their training
and they admitted that it was false you
know that it was well who did i don't i
don't think it's confirmed in any way
that kubrick directed anything about the
moon
no but he did a movie exactly before it
she doesn't want a space odyssey and you
know they say in the shining that you
know he left clues like you know the
little kids wearing an apollo 11 shirt i
know hey tim i'm a conspiracy theorist
i'm a tinfoil hot worm so i mean i'm
just i'm just saying i just what about
atlantis we oh i don't know but but but
tim i think you may i think you said you
know the best point is like uh you know
the government did have an incentive to
you know lie and i'll be honest when it
comes to the government i don't trust
him at all i don't trust him on anything
so it's hard for me to be like oh yeah
let me just take care i'll tell you i'll
tell you take a look at the uh space
feats accomplishments of the soviet
union in the united states they were
crushing us the soviet union was
crushing us on the one thing we defeated
them on was getting to the moon first
which is a reason why they would have
lied about it to be like hey we got
there first so but they say that russia
would have exposed us for it but i don't
know because you know all these same
people or at least accused us of it
yeah but you know at the end of the day
it's like if you don't think that we're
kind of in cahoots with everybody it's
like you know they want to it's let me
tell you something vladimir putin the
ruble is the strongest it's ever been so
if you don't think that this war is
benefiting russia you know you know how
i know we've been to the moon because we
came from the moon because the moon is
the ark and the reason the russians
didn't expose us because it's because
the us and the russians are actually
both working underneath the moon people
who control
space force yeah yeah i know we need it
well who is dianne feinstein i think
just said that space forces are most
important he pulled that up she just
said it so these people that you know
are supposedly socialists they want to
spend all our money in space i'm just
saying i think that you know it spends a
lot of money going and exploring these
planets that we could spend here it's
similar to the war in ukraine we need to
help out our citizens but the money
motivation for space exploration is more
of a morbid curiosity now
compared to
an optimism in the past
i i think it's great the the money spent
on space travel is spent here
the people who get the money for space
travel get that money buy things here
and expand the economy and the
technology developed from space travel
has widely improved the lives
what space technology is plastics
you don't think they would have invented
plastics without the space
either way it's their programs but but
also we're looking at uh mining
asteroids which is oh sure we're gonna
get diamonds from asteroids come on
you know did you see they just found
enough diamonds or gold i think in
africa uh you know trillions of dollars
worth of gold in africa so you know
these people where was that congo or
something yeah so you know they say
these precious materials oh there's old
residents we don't have any yeah like i
said earlier we have enough oil and gas
reserves in texas uh you know to support
the whole world if we can get to the
moon with a mining operation we can
access the lost ancient technology of
the ark
well it's a movie that just came out of
course of course
i'm just saying you know the government
i trust them with every decision that
they make and you saw bill clinton was
recently on james corden's show and said
like area 51 was not aliens or whatever
i just it's kind of like this there's a
guy warner von braun who was actually
brought over in a thing called operation
paperclip and warner von braun he
designed the rockets that actually you
know killed a lot of people in world war
ii and we brought him over and we gave
him immunity and let him create the nasa
program and you know what he said who is
best friends of the world the rockets in
world war ii
they performed wonderfully they just
landed on the wrong planet
uh well exactly but my point being is he
even said to get to the moon we need
rockets about uh twice the size of the
empire state building and warner von
braun uh said that and there's multiple
yeah but like that's a really long time
ago you know what i mean
so they do tell me let me just compare
1969 lincoln to a 2022 lincoln which is
uh you know has more technology
the modern one what do you yeah so do
you think technology goes backwards how
did our space technology i'm saying our
technology in 1969 how does it go
backwards we cannot go to the moon today
and nasa admits it we cannot travel 237
thousand miles what do they say to the
moon what are you talking about we
cannot have manned space flight through
the van gogh this uh google uh cannot go
through van allen radiation belt right
now it'll come up and and nasa will say
google cannot go through a van allen
radiation belt it should come up
right on youtube and it's like a person
saying oh uh you know we do we're trying
to develop technology to go to the moon
but we can't do it now so we don't have
the technology now tim to spin to send
human through the van allen radiation
belt yeah we were able to do it in 1969
so it's the only technology where did
where did nessa say that go to videos go
to videos click videos
and you'll see it'll see it's probably
you know obviously it gets all uh it's
like a woman uh talking about it and she
says we cannot go through the van allen
radiation belts now type in nasa too put
nasa in the search but my point being is
this video exists somebody will be able
to find it yeah but are you talking
about like a single individual or
we cannot go to the moon tim that's a
fact that nasa admits that
tim i'm not listen i'm telling you
there's multiple videos saying uh why
aren't they we cannot go to the moon i'm
telling you that's official story from
nasa but is that like you can't eat raw
milk no the kind of thing where like
they decided it's too dangerous for you
so now you can't do it here i'll find
the video but i can't and shouldn't are
two different things i'm telling you
nasa today cannot go to the moon yet in
1969 through 1972 with technology that
we accidentally destroyed pull up a
picture of the lunar lander right now if
you want to believe me just type in
picture of the lunar lander well let's
start we'll start here and then we'll
keep moving forward so i'm trying to
find out where nasa said we cannot get
to the van ellen i found a forbes
article saying we actually can oh
yeah years ago
yeah but let me i gotta find it i should
have had five years ago
uh uh it's it's just there's so many
videos i gotta now my service is
terrible but i'm telling you tim we
gotta find the video where it says it's
very clear they say we cannot go through
the van out go to youtube right now go
to youtube well
let me read this real quick
so this is this is them saying uh what
is it uh
they there were uh 0.38 rad
getting the radiation dose of getting
two ct blah blah the atmosphere can be a
danger but they made it through it
uh the apollo trips we wanted to send
the astronauts through a sparse region
of the belts and try to get through them
quickly
so yeah i don't know tim the farthest we
can go according to them is the
international space station which is
roughly about two minutes who's them i
don't know nasa is it roughly about 200
miles from uh the surface of earth we
cannot go past low or oh type in type in
cannot go past low earth orbit uh barack
obama type that in right now low earth
orbit morocco i'm not trying to be boss
you just said you didn't believe the
government
but this
well of course but but now go to the
video uh go now click videos click
videos it ought to be the first one that
aggregates to the top it says for the
united states the landing the leading
space fairing nation for nearly half a
century to be without carriage to low
earth orbit and with no human
exploration capability to go beyond
earth orbit no capability to go beyond
low earth orbit the moon is 237 000
miles according to them that's past low
earth orbit you're reading it wrong no
type in barack obama i i've got the
quote right here literally it's right
here in a quote he says
there uh and with no human exploration
capability to go beyond earth orbit for
an indeterminate time into the future
destines our nation to become one of
second or even third-rate stature he's
not saying we've never had the
capabilities and we currently don't
please type in video just listen to what
barack obama has to say because you're
gonna get all this stuff and that's not
the third one down the third one third
one down go down third one this one yes
you got it you gotta this video right
here yes
so let me start by being
extremely clear clear i am 100 committed
to the mission of nasa and its future
because this is a minute long video but
there's a shorter one where he says it
but we can watch it
you might want to play it on 1.5 speed
because broadening our capabilities in
space will continue to serve our society
in ways that we can seriously imagine
because exploration will once more
inspire wonder in a new generation
sparking passions and launching careers
and because ultimately if we fail to
press forward in the pursuit of
discovery we are seeing our future and
we are seeding that essential element of
the american character
i know there have been a number of
questions raised about my
administration's plan for space
exploration especially in this part of
florida where so many rely on nasa as a
source of income as well as a source of
pride and community we start by
increasing nasa's budget by six billion
dollars over the next five years by
buying the services of space
transportation rather than the vehicles
themselves we can continue to ensure
rigorous safety standards are met but we
will also accelerate the pace of
innovations as companies from young
startups to established leaders
compete to design and build and launch
new means of carrying people and
materials out of our atmosphere
yes pursuing this new strategy will
require that we revise the old strategy
in part this is because the old strategy
including the constellation program was
not fulfilling its promise in many ways
that's not just myself okay edit it out
you got to go to the you got to click
back go to youtube and you're going to
see a short version type in barack obama
low earth orbit you got to go to youtube
obama low earth orbit and there'll be
like a 10 second clip of him saying it
that we cannot go through yeah that's
him speaking uh we got to go down
you got to see
it's it's that speech there he says he
cannot go through low earth orbit i
promise you dude i mean it's just kind
of annoying i mean i read the quote
where he said no but you have to hear
him say because he doesn't say that
quote he does not say that he says it
says it much different he says we do not
have the ability to go with you but it
can't even reach low earth orbit i mean
we have transcript right here right
i'm just saying i mean you know you call
me a conspiracy theorist but this is
barack obama saying you people you know
the same thing the same people that type
this transcript are the ones that said
that uh joe biden didn't say uh sure
he says sure it's comfortable but it
can't even reach low earth orbit and
that obviously is in striking contrast
to the falcon 9 rocket we just saw on
the launch pad which will be tested for
the very first time uh
i mean here's the issue like anything
they don't want shared we're not gonna
be able to just google search you know
what i mean
well it's but on youtube there's a lot
of conspiracy go to go to youtube and
then type in upload date type in barack
obama low earth orbit then type in
upload date and then it'll be one of the
first ones type in barack obama low
earth orbit there it is recent search
suggestion
uh it would be a really short one and
did you do it by upload date
uh
search by upload date where is that to
the right to the right to the right
okay and we want to go from reverse uh
yeah we want to go down where it's that
short i think is that maybe that nine
second one up there obama says you can't
go nine second one this one is that say
what does that say next day this is it
early in the next decade a set of crude
flights will test and prove the systems
required for exploration beyond low
earth orbit
in the next decade but i don't think you
understand what that means and second of
all this is a nine second out of context
clip well you can watch the whole
context i'm just saying he admits today
with the technology well you can fact
check me out all you want people are
working on he says today that we cannot
go through low earth orbit we cannot
take man flight barack obama said it
right the idea but if it doesn't exist
it means we don't we don't we don't have
it we don't fund it we don't have it yet
we did have it in 1969 through 1970 and
then they stopped
so you're telling me technology goes
backwards you actually believe that like
there there was a lot for a long time
for a long period they wondered how the
romans did concrete underwater
right for for a long period we couldn't
build skyscrapers you're comparing space
flight with concrete tim
okay how do they build the pyramid well
i'm just saying we can't we can't
rebuild the pyramids right we can and we
know how because i've read about the
construction of the pyramids oh you've
got to be kidding these these freemasons
i'm just saying
so now you're saying it does go
backwards well exactly my point being
though not spatial it's really simple we
had a reason to go to the moon when we
were in the cold war afterwards we
abandoned the projects and abandoned the
rockets and they found the disrepair and
no one cares anymore
now
we have no real reason to build and
expand in that in that direction or we
don't have companies that want to do it
nor do we have the government want to do
it and in 2010 barack obama was saying
we need to start building the machines
to do this but we don't have the
machines today you admit that right
i don't know based on what he said
twelve years ago we did not have
machines capable of doing it that
doesn't mean the technology exists
they did not build them and barack
obama's literally saying in these videos
we're going to put six billion dollars
into nasa to build these to do these
things and we can't go today they keep
saying we're gonna go to the moon and
let me tell you something you know this
as a successful businessman it would be
the biggest marketing tool in the world
if they were able to go to the moon and
yet we can't so i mean but i don't
understand why you're saying we can't
like elon musk
building starship okay google if elon
musk says we can go to the moon we can't
elon musk is saying we can go to mars we
can't go to the moon
we cannot send manned spacecraft they
can say they can spin that cinder rover
elon musk said on twitter like a week
ago we will be on mars and
you will see men on mars in our lifetime
he also wants to put a computer chip in
your brain to be able to park your tesla
that's not a question that that's a
morality question but a question of the
possibility of the spaceships well you
guys can believe the moon landing all
you want but it's so fake and the
government and it's so fake yeah the
record of barack obama said we do not
have a base on the moon i would
immediately think we probably have a
base on them yeah
well there was a there was a skit about
that who did that was the whitest kids
you know
have you seen that one no he's like uh
he's like uh there are bears on the
bears on the moon he's like and they're
like did you submit there that was a
great schedule and then someone goes
are we invading iran he goes
you got me you got me and then yeah you
know okay last thing because then we'll
get off the moon because people are
gonna get so mad at me just type in a
picture of the lunar lander please lunar
lander huh yeah just type in a picture
of it because i want you to show you
this great technology
now type in images now i want you to you
know look at that thing and you tell me
that that so you you you know the idea
of the lunar lander is that they were
able to go what happened was we were
able to send a craft to the moon get in
the moon's orbit then michael collins
stayed in the craft and then that thing
was able to escape from this spacecraft
and it was able to land on the moon
then buzz and neil were able to take a
car out of there and drive it around and
play golf on the moon and this is the
official story they actually snuck a
golf club google snuck a golf club onto
the moon so you're telling me nasa with
technology you're able to just oh bring
your own bag you know yet on an airplane
if your bag weighs over 40 pounds you
can't even take it on but these guys can
take out the technology makes no sense
well i'm saying it's the joke is the
fact that they can just bring stuff
on the on the most intense mission we've
ever been on but but look at this
technology you see that you see how
that's held together does that not look
like that does that not look uh like
2022 technology i don't i don't
understand what you think is wrong with
it i'm saying that is the fakest looking
crap i've ever seen in my life that's
garbage
well you got it you got to zoom in on it
look at that what is that tin foil and
what is that literally is foil yes okay
and that's paper and this is according
to them this you can google this that
when in the in when they were doing uh
the uh you know practicing for the
mission that if they dropped a tool that
it was so thin the tool would fall
through
through through the through the uh
whatever you want to call it the walls
of the lunar lander you can google this
as tools would would break through the
wall of the lunarland look at that that
is tape tim that's space tape bud that
went through did you know they put duct
tape on airplanes
okay
when i worked two airplanes when i
worked at o'hare passengers would freak
out all the time watching mechanics put
mechanics put duct tape and they would
be like oh oh and they would okay so why
can't we recreate that then if it's just
tape if it says we can't recreate it
because we can't go to the moon today
why can't who says that barack obama
here's you're conflating
the lack of funding and motivation with
the lack of technology tim if there's
you don't think there's motivated to go
to the moon you're kidding me but for
what for what what's what's on the move
because it could be a marketing
technique you know the same reason oh
yeah let's spend 50 billion dollars to
market when we were at war i get it now
they gave 80 billion dollars to the
ukraine to fight a war we can't get
people to fund real journalism but we
can get all this money to go to ukraine
come on right you can get money for a
war you can't get money for journalism
why would tim get money explain to me
where did where did the car come out of
that machine
i i'd have to research i think you're
wrong about everything you've already
presented no i'm not so i'm right but
get you can't come here and be alike the
car came out of that and have me just
assuming it did well okay type in the
the moon landing rover and it's look at
the car just look at that jeep frame
yeah i've seen it yeah a jeep frame they
were able to in a machine in that thing
they're able to pop out a jeep and drive
around
you can make a lot of assumptions
and i would argue
there is a good reason why the us would
fake such a thing but none of what you
prov you've presented is actually
evidence that you're right it's
conjecture based on
out of context quotes and it does
nothing for me to believe you now you
might be right you don't have to believe
me i'm just saying you can you know you
can just believe the government i mean
you know that's what you know that's you
don't have to believe either though
i'm just saying the technology here
i'll tell you one of the weakest points
well this is the thing but think about
their batteries one of the weakest
issues the foil on
on on the lander right here i actually
know a little about and i understand the
concept using lightweight reflective
foil mylar for instance you seem to not
understand that so when you say that
it's a red flag for me being like well
if you don't understand that tim i would
assume the like outside of your
arguments are incorrect well listen i'm
not saying that you know you can't say
that you're allowed to have an opinion
but i'm just saying if you actually do
the research you actually looked into it
like your buddy joe rogan did for a long
time
you can pretty much find all the holes
in the story of the moon mission it's
just it's just laughable and i know
we're you know we're kind of going on a
tangent and you're going to know for
sure like i tried looking up and granted
there's the issue of google suppresses
things so it's like not not easy to be
like i'm gonna google it and we can
prove that it's a real thing but uh all
i can say is this
i don't know
about the things you're saying
nothing that i've pulled up has actually
confirmed what you've been saying okay
type in this and more importantly i want
to make the point when i understand the
concept of mylar or lightweight
reflective foil and you don't it's a red
flag it's not even about that because
the foil they said was so thin that a
tool could fall through you can well
that's that's but i've actually gone to
labs for jet propulsion and like saw
them working on these things i actually
have a video of a rocket test at uh at
x-core in in the mojave desert and i
watch them fly a rocket plane
so when i actually sit down with rocket
engineers and machinists who are
building these parts who explain these
things to me and i know even the tiniest
bit as like a layman who's like oh i
heard about that and then you say
something that's completely incorrect i
say okay well what did i say and correct
it that's that that's foil that's space
foil you you acted like the foil was
somehow proof that didn't make sense i'm
just saying that does not look like very
advanced technology to me that's what
i'm saying because you're basing your
mind your view on like sci-fi movies no
i'm looking and using common sense that
looks like it's held together by literal
tape and an issue is i'm right that it's
tape you're wrong about foil and you
don't know anything okay well type in
this just type in astronauts hands
injured from the space suit so multiple
yes what i'm just saying we're not going
to get it done in half an hour i know
okay this is the last thing but this is
the last thing i want to say and this is
a fact multiple astronauts when they
came back in the pictures they had scars
on their hands so this technology that
was so incredible and on the moon in the
sunlight it's 200 degrees in the shade
it goes to instantly negative 200
degrees now you can talk about the space
technology to get there all day long we
cannot even recreate the suits and on
top of that back then these suits the
most magical suits in the on earth with
one battery that can go change 400
degrees in instant listen was not even
able to get the thumb mechanism right
for multiple aspects because there's
astronauts that admitted that they had
thumb injuries when they came back the
problem with conspiracy theories is that
you choose to believe some narratives
not others i believe all the natives
it's fake that's all i'm saying so so if
they can't get the glove right then they
can't get a battery technology that can
make a suit change instantly 40 degrees
the problem with conspiracy theories is
that you've made a determination and now
you agree with the evidence that back to
determination well that's with
everything right i mean no no no i don't
have that position my position is i
don't know
well i mean i well i do know that we
didn't i know that you're you're like
you you you acted like the foil was an
incorrect thing and having actually i
didn't say it's incorrect i said it
looks like garbage it looks like a space
and you're shy wrong right so that
that's wrong what do you mean i'm wrong
you don't think that you think that that
looks good to you the foil specifically
is a red flag in your argument because
you don't understand okay what what
other than the foil what is that what is
that material i don't know what's the
what's the material next to that this is
a blanket
compromised of 25 layers of capped on
tape gold leaf uh there's there's data
about it we could read into it right so
so let me stress this point because i
don't think you're getting it
i don't know anything about the lander
you don't either i know a little bit you
looked at it and said that does not look
right i said okay actually i've been to
a jet propulsion laboratory in the
mojave where i watched them do tests and
they explained to me heat resistance
return all that stuff and so you're
comparing apples and oranges but okay so
so you're misunderstanding my point is
when i've actually gone to uh a
spaceport and looked at this stuff yeah
and have witnessed the tests of it and
actually flights of the of the they they
did the rocket test when they went in
space in the rocket plane they just flew
it around uh and then you come out and
say that looks wrong to me i'm like okay
well you're missing key context here no
so i'm not going to take your narrative
which is based on conjecture don't
believe me that's the first thing i want
to say is i'm not a role model i'm not
do not ever believe me i just think we
should question the reality in which you
live in and there's a lot of there's a
lot of unanswered questions with this
when you talk about the original footage
that they accidentally deleted you know
they recorded over all the titles
someone said you were wrong the rover
was not on the first mission
it was on 15 16 and 17 apollo 15 16 and
17. so this actually so you were wrong
and that's the problem i have yeah but i
said where's the rover on that you were
wrong there wasn't a rover yeah but look
look at the lunar lander with a rover
look at that look how fake that looks
i'm just saying it doesn't pass the
smell test and you don't want to give it
the smell test because you know red
white and blue i wouldn't be surprised
if nasa and the government opted to
throw false information out there so
that other people couldn't recreate
their process just like with area 51
they told people there were little green
men in the stuff to so if someone went
rogue and wanted to spill the beans
they're going to sound like a crazy
person well i'm just saying guys you
know you can believe the land i don't
think you're wrong to cast doubt on it
but you are saying with
certainty that we didn't
do the moon landing well i don't know a
lot of stuff you know it i in my heart i
know and that's all that matters because
you know what we get to choose to react
how you believe
in my heart i believe and i believe that
i'm a thousand percent right but we can
debate the moon landing all day long i
do debate people on it but i'm not even
trying to debate you tim because i like
you and i appreciate your opinion oh i
thought it was fun thanks for checking
out this clip from timcast irl come hang
out live monday through friday at 8pm
eastern time super chat we'll even
answer some of your questions if you
want to check out the after hours
censored show go to timcast.com and
become a member we put those up monday
through thursday at 11 pm they're very
funny not very family friendly we'll
love to see you there thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time